[Music]
so hey folks
welcome to the 68th dark horse podcast
live stream i am here as always with dr
heather heing
it has been chaos at every scale
we are going to attempt to integrate
everything
um topics that we have been considering
separately have crashed into each other
and so that's going to leave us a little
bit of a task for
intermingling things but uh why don't
you set us in motion in the right
direction
well just a first a couple of
announcements uh so
on on my patreon you can get access to
private monthly q a and right now
is the open the 48 hours open session
for
uh people to ask questions which we then
sift through and answer on the last
sunday of the month so
if you were thinking about doing that
and wanted to um be in a position to ask
a question
you can go to my patreon heather heing
now
and you also had an announcement similar
to one that you gave last week
yes we are going to give away another
invite to clubhouse clubhouse is
taking off in the most remarkable
fashion yesterday i
stumbled in just to spend a few minutes
listening to see what was going on and
who did i find there but joe rogan
and when i walked in the room he
immediately called me up on stage and
suddenly there i was in real time
talking to joe and
lex friedman and a number of other folks
tim dillon who we uh
gently chastised last week so anyway
things are afoot there
um and if you would like an invite uh
the
moderator gator is the the go-to person
and um we will give that out at the end
all right um okay so where we're going
today is we are going to talk a little
bit
about um what what portland where we are
portland oregon experienced in this last
week
um from not just a societal perspective
but an ecological one
and then we are going to discuss i'm
going to i want to pick up on something
uh that you and daniel schmachtenberger
talked about in that excellent
conversation which again as i
recommended last week i highly recommend
uh that people listen to and i finally
did listen to it
uh and so i want to pick up on something
from there about the nature of really
excellent education
the nature of good education and the
nature of bad education which is most of
what passes for education now
and from there move into
talking about the new york times
suggests chiding us
uh that maybe all of us not us
specifically but
all of us should really abandon some of
our critical thinking skills if we want
to move forward in the world
and from there this is where you know i
was thinking along these lines and you
were thinking along the lines of
effectively a kind of fact-checking
apocalypse that is coming down the pike
at us and so we are going to
we're going to mesh these things uh talk
about them together
and um and then we'll finish with just a
little bit on dung beetles
including um just a new a new
interesting thing that's going on in
dung beetle land which we will finish on
literal dung beetles the earlier part
will cover a fair number of figurative
dung beetles rolling dung
across the internet and other places
metaphorical dung beetles that will
end with literal dung beetles uh
including a video that i took actually
in the amazon
uh 13 months it turns out it was 13
months ago today um this video that i
found
on my phone from when we were at
tippatini in the ecuador and amazon
uh the last time we went almost anywhere
fantastic
fantastic yeah oh and i guess um one
other thing so
as as we were about to tell you we were
you know basically incommunicado all
week and had to cancel a number of
conversations we were supposed to be
having um but megan murphy did
uh post the conversation that she and i
had back in january
and that's on youtube now and um i made
a couple errors in it
which i'm not going to specify here they
are they are significant to me but won't
be to most
people listening who don't care deeply
about some of the
um arcane biological things but i think
it's a really good conversation it
actually gets at some of this question
that we keep on coming back to of like
what does it mean
to follow the science what you know what
is science and and
what therefore should you be doing as
you try to navigate the world
scientifically
so i do i recommend that conversation on
megan murphy's youtube channel and that
meta conversation is so important
you and i got dragged in the direction
of the philosophy of science which i
don't think either of us regarded
as super important until graduate school
dragged in graduate school
dragged in graduate school largely by
arnold kluge
your primary mentor and
anyway i have never regretted a moment
we spent
learning about it or thinking about it
it's it's amazing how many scientific
issues actually come down to some slight
new
nuance of the philosophy of science with
which although phds are supposed to be
philosophers of science right um it's a
doctor of philosophy
most just never bother to think about it
and having never bothered to think about
it they screw up little things and it's
every bit as devastating
as uh the failure to meet even basic
assumptions and statistics
this is absolutely right in fact i once
said to a uh
a philosopher and you know a phd in
philosophy which would seem to be
somewhat redundant but
um and that when she was
dismissing some scientific ways of
thinking
as being a philosophical if not
downright anti-philosophical and i said
but of course you know all science all
modern scientists have degrees in
philosophy it's what we are supposed to
be doing she literally
laughed at me and you know i was able i
was able to demonstrate that that
many of us do but in fact it's it's by
far not all of them and i think it's
part of
it is part of why you see people with
the credentials
not actually being able to demonstrate
that they even know what what science is
and and certainly not being able to
demonstrate you know how you would do it
or under what conditions you should in
fact
trust a result that you find and under
what conditions you shouldn't
all right excellent so let's uh let's
get to it let's get to it
um this is the uh segment that we were
thinking of calling
drunk without power drunk without power
you'll see why
shortly yeah so are we going to start
with the pictures um
actually yeah just just a just a tiny
bit of description first so it turns so
we
a week ago today there was there was
snow outside there was snow on the
ground and we were saying yeah it's
pretty rare
for portland oregon to have snow on the
ground um and we had a series it was
either two or three distinct
weather events snow and ice storms that
came through
um that came through portland and
southwest washington and a lot of
northwest oregon and it wasn't it
certainly wasn't the largest weather
event that this area has seen
uh even um you know in living history
even
but it did cause the greatest power
outage in oregon history
actually in terms of the number of power
customers affected so at one point more
than a third of portlanders
were out of power and people from a lot
of the surrounding areas lost power a
lot of people are still
out of power our power went out um
mid-morning on valentine's day and we
just got it back on thursday so we were
out for four full days
for some of that time our cell service
was also out i literally in order to
make sure that we didn't miss something
you know in order to cancel something
that needed to be canceled actually to
climb a hill to where i could get you
know cell service from an adjoining
tower because you know just
everything in our neighborhood was um
was
out the power took out the cell the uh
cell service because the
the towers weren't getting power either
and i'm sure they have some backup but
it didn't last and it would you know
suddenly we were cut off
it didn't last yeah the cell towers
didn't actually fall but
many many power lines were down actually
in the street visible to us
multiple different streets within blocks
of our home
lots of downed trees and branches and
for me some of what was super
interesting and yet we know this from
ecology
is how patchy it was right like there
are areas near us that never lost power
at all
and certainly if you don't live among
the trees you were less likely to lose
power unless you were getting power from
an area that did have them because a
large part of what happened
um was trees falling on lines although
that's not the only thing that happened
yeah so let's um you know for those of
you who have not had the uh
the joy of experiencing an ice storm
let's just talk for a moment about
what it is and why it happens i'm
thinking about people in los angeles who
may have
only sort of vaguely thought about this
where we grew up right and until we
moved to michigan we're
somewhat well i guess we both spent
times in the time in the sierras so we
were familiar with ice storms already
but yeah although ice storms
are a special weather condition it's
really a combination of weather
conditions where
um things down here on earth cool down
below freezing but they're warm enough
at the point that the precipitation
falls that it doesn't fall as snow
it falls as liquid water very close to
the freezing point and then upon hitting
very cold
surfaces it freezes and accumulates and
the thing about it is it's
really heavy and so my recollection is
that when we lived in michigan
ice storms happened they caused damage
but in general because power lines got
too heavy
the trees were actually much better
adapted to it but because it's fairly
rare
out here in the pacific northwest our
trees
they don't budget for it because that
would be very expensive and reduce their
competitive viability
so this is and this is actually exactly
i think one of the central points here
that
it's easy for people in places with
reliably bad winter weather
to mock uh the regions of the country
like texas right now
like portland uh this last week like los
angeles whenever it rains even right
um for being unprepared and incapable of
dealing
and um it is true that socially
societally like if you
if you don't have experience you're
driving in the rain even rain is tough
for you if you don't have experience
driving in the snow and ice even that is
difficult for you
and um and that you know that is just a
truth and so you know is it
you reported that apparently portland
has three snowplows
that is what i learned from the portland
subreddit which is you know it seems
super low except most years it none of
them get used right
so this this social truth by which
humans tend to mock other humans is
mirrored by a deeper and much older
ecological truth which
is that the tree is here the trees not
the people but the trees here
don't tend to deal with ice buildup on
their branches and so
whereas in michigan where ice storms you
know
some kind of ice storm happened every
year and we were just using michigan
because that
has happened happens to be where we
lived for eight years or something
in grad school um the trees didn't
explode
right like they they dealt with it and
you still had power outages because
power lines don't deal well with ice
buildup but the trees were better
adapted to a situation because it was
more common
and any place that you get extreme
weather events that are not common
the organisms there are less likely to
be able to deal with it and so we have
you know in portland
a particularly you know ridiculous
situation um
because i think of the repeated freeze
thaw cycles with so
many so much buildup but then you know
texas it's even
more out of the ordinary what happened
and so um
you know they're they're dealing with
their own kind of hell as a result
not of you know them being incompetent
and
but rather of the entire system
including the system absent humans
not having this is a regular feature of
their lives yeah in texas this can
happen
if three people leave their freezers
open on the same afternoon
right um it's a very rare thing for it
to get cold enough
to create have you in fact ever been in
texas i have been to texas yeah i know
i've been there with you but obviously
that's not true right
no that's oh true geez no most jokes are
not true
um i don't even strive for it anymore no
i mean obviously that was a joke but
like
you know texas gets cold the way the
high desert in california
you know gets cold right not all of it
you know texas is gigantic and gulf
coast is different from
you know up near the up near the borders
with the mountain states but
um but this level of storm was unusual
yeah but now my joke is just making me
look dumb
oh i know what you're thinking you're
thinking many of them do is that no
no i was just thinking should i applaud
no i'm not sorry don't apologize
all right um so let's look at some
pictures zach you want to
put up a series just to give people a
sense so
all right here we have some ferns and
you can see there's a thick coating of
ice on them these are sword ferns
uh skip ahead one okay here you see you
can really get a sense for how much
ice is on the plants this is a
rhododendron
and you know there's a thick it's like
an inch thick
coating of ice uh on each of these
leaves and
you know that's one thing if it's one
branch which is
robust to wind and this branch is
standing up to it reasonably well but
you can imagine scaling that up over an
entire tree
how much extra weight the tree is
dealing with in this circumstance and i
must say we didn't get terrible wind
this time
sometimes the combination of wind and
ice storm happens
you know it's every i don't know five
years maybe
eight years pacific northwest we get
such a thing but that's really
devastating too
all right skip ahead one all right here
you can see again every branch there's
like multiple times the weight of the
branch in
ice sitting on the surface of the branch
every surface was cold and they all
accumulated it
okay here you can see a close-up and i
don't know if your screen's good you can
see the crystalline formations on the
surface of this
uh ice this is just a branch it must be
you know
eight times as heavy as it normally
would be
all right and again one more
here uh i spent a lot of time trying to
capture a droplet falling off of one of
these
bits of ice all right and then here's
what happens is
the trees build up the ice some branch
that was within tolerances is suddenly
way above tolerances collapses and here
one has
landed on a power line and
short-circuited it and the power
everywhere downstream of this is off
including
um the signals and this was all over the
place
um there were you know there were
multiple entire trees down in many
locations often across the road
and the problem is that the fruit the
system has become so
fragile that in fact the power company
initially was reporting
very long periods of time in which they
expected to repair and then they
pulled all of their estimates they
stopped estimating altogether right what
they realized was that every time they
got something
they found a problem and they hooked it
back up something downstream was
short-circuited and they would pop
that breaker there was a branch they
didn't realize on another power line
that immediately short
shorted out right you know number of
houses in fact our power came back on
for five minutes the afternoon it went
out
and uh and then we were plunged into
darkness for another three and a half
years yes in fact it came back early and
i believe my exact words were something
like
um i'll believe it if it lasts more than
five minutes and that's about as long as
it lasts
went out again um okay and then there's
one more which is the result of all of
this
is here uh we were in the dark uh
drunk without power so but with curry
powder apparently well sure
yeah i mean you wouldn't want to have a
beverage without curry powder and this
is the hot curry powder by the way yes
yeah i did have the impressions to make
a giant pot of soup that first night
which uh
which because we have a gas stove we
were able to heat up every night yep
yep all right um cool okay
so let us let us move on to our next
biggest
main topic and we'll start um by
i'm just gonna actually read some
someone thank you uh actually
wrote a transcript of your and daniel's
conversation
and really again i recommend that that
conversation very very highly
um but i was i was taken by several
pieces of it but this one this piece in
particular which happens at the hour and
51 minute mark in your conversation with
daniel schwarzenberger
the only this is daniel talking the only
answer out of the oppression or chaos is
the comprehensive education of everyone
in the capacity to understand at least
three things
they have to increase their first person
second person and third person
epistemics
their third person epistemics is the
easiest philosophy of science formal
logic
their ability to actually make sense of
base reality through appropriate
methodology
and find appropriate confidence margins
second person is
my ability to make sense of your
perspective can i steal man where you're
coming from can i inhabit your position
well
and if i'm not oriented to do that then
i'm not going to find the synthesis of a
dialectic
i'm going to be arguing for one side of
partiality harming something that will
actually harm the thing i care about in
the long run
and then first person can i notice my
own biases and my own susceptibilities
and my own group identity issues and
whatever well enough that those aren't
the things that run me
um yeah i'll go out read just a little
bit more when i
daniel look at the ancient greek
enlightenment first person was the stoic
tradition second person was the socratic
tradition third person was the
aristotelian tradition
there's a mirror of all those in
modernity we need new cultural
enlightenment now where everyone values
good sense making about themselves about
others about base reality and good
quality dialogue with other people that
are also sense making to emerge to a
collective consciousness
and collective intelligence that is more
than our individual intelligence
and so that we have some basis of
something that isn't chaos but that also
isn't oppression
because it's emergent more than imposed
so it's cultural enlightenment or
bust as far as i'm concerned so
uh you know as almost everything that
you guys talked about both of you were
like i want to go 18 places from that
right
um and so one of one of the places to go
from that
is um you know my sense was this is
as as he says this is exactly what
education should be doing
most good education most good but
traditional education doesn't actually
even attempt
the first or the second person
epistemics it attempts the third
and sometimes it gets there second he
doesn't use this
language exactly but i think second
second person epistemics is basically
theory of mind
um and um you know that's not unique
to humans uh there you know there are
other organisms that engage in theory of
mind but the ability to place yourself
in someone else's perspective and really
and and really understand that they see
things differently than you do
is critical to this collective
consciousness which of course we have
talked about a lot
and then first first person epistemics
is what we have called in our book
actually
um the laboratory of the self and
as educators you know listening to
daniel i thought well you know
you're your bret conversation with
daniel our friend
um and you know in the very end of that
conversation he
um sort of salutes us as educators and
is very kind um
but i i do think uh that you and i
specifically without ever having
categorized it this way like i really
love his categorization
um we're trying and frankly usually
succeeding
in doing all three things in both
modeling
first second and third person epistemics
for our students
and also expecting them to derive the
abilities too
and engage with each other having found
their own
first person and second per and first
person second person and third person
epistemics
and you know it's going to be a little
bit different um how you engage in the
world and
as you point out in another point in the
conversation as we have talked about
you know for decades um you know there's
a piece of science
that maybe can't be taught i disagree
with you a little bit about on this but
you know the
the formulation of hypothesis is the
black box
that you know that that is is
is the thing that is not taught when
you're teaching the scientific method
that sort of just always appears
like okay now you've got hypothesis and
now everything downstream is a
scientific method but
um i guess i would say
look by comparison uh at what for
instance
you know diversity equity and inclusion
so-called education
is doing it's this pathetic shallow
nightmare of prejudice and insipid
thinking it's anti-educational
it imagines it it abandons third-person
epistemics claiming that that's
i don't even know white supremacist or
besides like who knows what
it never even pretends to engage in
second person epistemics like there is
no
you there is no outsider in this world
view of
uh the the the woke revolution
the the post-modern takeover of the
academy and
media and everything and it presumes and
i actually made this point we were
talking about white fragility
back in june or july it presumes that
the personal
lived experience of the person talking
is
what is true for everyone it is like the
supreme form of narcissism that is
anti-educational and it i think it
exactly
to use daniel's characterization
categorization
it takes a single experience and
imagines
that you know the first person
epistemics uh and
um sprays it you know scattershot across
the entire landscape as if
it applies to everything actually uh i
want to go back to a couple things
one there's an argument to be made
that it um
deifies the you know the personal
experience
and negates you know the thing about
what we call laboratory of the self
is that you will never have better
information
on or you will never even have really
high quality information on what it's
like to be the next person
like you're the next person to me you
and i spend a ton of time together and
we've spent
many many years together so i probably
know you as well as anybody
can but you know it's still
a step removed right but i have very
good information on what it's like to be
inside my conscious mind there's lots of
stuff i can't access but
in any case to take the um
the so the data is very good for self
but it's not a substitute for a
dispassionate analysis of the world the
point is it's actually
an interesting source of information
that you then want to test against
patterns that you can see externalized
and neither of those is a substitute for
the second person
right actually engaging with another
person's mind and hearing when they say
things that surprise you
and not immediately saying you're bigot
or you're wrong or try again
but oh you actually have a fundamentally
different understanding of or experience
of the world
let's explore that right so in some
sense i think what you and i are going
to land on and you know the weird thing
here you and i
entered the public consciousness as
evergreen became
a an absurdity yeah and so you and i are
constantly battling the fact that
actually evergreen the founders of
evergreen had something very very right
yes right and it went off the rails
because they didn't get everything right
and nobody fixed the problems but
um but the basic point is there was
something absolutely magical about not
being stuck in any one of these realms
and we've seen
failures stuck in all of these realms
we've seen an obsession
with dialogue that you know that demotes
the
seminar right there you go yeah um we've
seen
you know an obsession with personal
experience and you know in other places
you know when as graduate students we
occasionally
uh i remember john vandermeer brought us
into a class
of central american graduate students in
costa rica
yeah and the culture was very very
different in fact it was so deferential
right and the problem was well you can't
do science
you know you can't innovate in science
if you're deferential to ideas that are
certainly partially wrong you have to be
in a mode to challenge and so
anyway any one of these but there is a
cultural expectation of not challenging
the authority figure
which is as you say antithetical to
actually becoming a scientist
right so in some sense the you know the
discovery is you need all three of these
things in play
yeah in the dynamic in order to make
real useful progress and anytime you've
defaulted to one you lose
even defaulting to two you lose you need
all three
and okay so one thing is the day before
joe rogan showed up on clubhouse
there was a discussion on clubhouse
about the day that shall forever after
be known as the day before joe rogan
showed up
well here's the thing for anybody who is
not paying attention to clubhouse
i know this is weird but you know
joe rogan hops in there and suddenly a
room goes to seven
thousand people with three i thought it
was maxed at five thousand well it was
but it then got to seven thousand and
then while joe was in the room the
engineers
changed it and it became eight thousand
okay right but anyway the point is joe's
showing up there
just to check it out is unfortunately a
terrible heisenberg problem where it's
like
joe can't check out clubhouse because
clubhouse obsesses over him and then it
gets
spread on twitter etc but um but anyway
the thing is if you go back to
the joe rogan experience right the joe
rogan experience
does contain all three of these layers
yes it does
this room that was on clubhouse the day
before joe showed up was
is joe rogan a danger to science or
words to that effect and this brought a
bunch of us into the room joe wasn't
there of course
um but lex friedman and me and eric
were in the room trying to explain why
joe rogan is actually a huge
asset to science and that it is really a
misunderstanding of how science works
that causes people to even formulate the
question
right and so that you know you can see
how it all
all would play out but um final thing i
want to say on your
intro there is i know what you're
disagreeing with me about with respect
to
the formulation of hypotheses and
whether or not i can be taught
there's like two components right
there's the once you have an idea of
what might be going on a system
in a system how do you make it into a
hypothesis that you can teach
right the problem the thing you can't
teach is how you traffic in wrong ideas
right such that you can spot one that is
in the category of wrong ideas but might
actually be right
but so i mean we we should talk a lot a
lot a lot about education
for the rest of our lives really because
we did never planning to become so
become really i'm just going to say it
like extraordinary educators
without ever having any of the training
and i think that helped yeah maybe
because of that
right right and because we both had such
totally different educational
experiences through all of our schooling
and we're intimately familiar with each
other and therefore each other's
experiences
we walked in being able to model okay
you you are a student who doesn't look
anything like i've ever experienced
before
i still bet you have something to offer
let's figure let's let's figure out how
to draw that out
how to help you realize that you
actually have something to offer as
opposed to treating me as
an antagonist that you're just trying to
get get through the class
through so um
one of the things that i did most of the
first weeks of most of my programs
was this exercise actually that john
vandermeer again so john vandenberg was
one of our graduate student um
graduate school professors uh who's a
neo-tropical biologist
and we spent a summer he basically
created this field course in tropical
ecology
and um and conservation um in costa rica
for us and
four or four other grad students
something and then he had an elder grad
student who was effectively ta so it was
like
eight of us i mean i could name everyone
if i thought about it but a very small
group
that he spent you know six seven weeks
touring around all these different
places in costa rica which of course
became some of the basis for me
creating my own study abroad programs
later although i never did it in costa
rica
um he ran us through an exercise that
was from the organization
for tropical studies which was the you
know standard bearer of like how you
become a tropical ecologist you go and
take one of these four week classes and
they just didn't happen to have any of
the year that we were
interested in doing this so he created
this for us and what the exercise is as
you know
is the professor takes um each of the
students out to some place in nature
with just a pen and paper hope really
hopefully nothing else
and um and parks them out of
out of view certainly hopefully out of
sight of any other human being and says
i'll be back for you in two hours don't
move unless
your life depends on it um and just sit
and be and watch and listen and
and you know and and use all of your
senses
you know depending on where you are at
taste is you know sometimes off the
table
appropriately but um and then at some
point
that your brain has quieted down enough
to stop telling you how very bored it is
and how very much you want to get on the
phone or
you know get some skittles or you know
whatever it is that you are you know
just too
antsy to sit and just be start noticing
what is going on around you
and start writing down questions and
it's just it's just questions
and uh and then after two hours comes
back
go back and um and then the next part of
the exercise i think he did with us
right away
but this is something that i did with
almost all of my students uh and you
know i had 25
or 50 depending and um you know i did
this i did this in
panama i did i think we did it in
ecuador um
i did it in the skylines of eastern
washington i did it in the san juans i
did it
in a number of places and the
so far all we've heard is you know
students come back hopefully with some
questions hopefully as many as 20 but
whatever
that they have had about things that
they are observing that are happening
outside of their own brain
so you know questions about why am i so
bored or you know like
less interested in those for for this
perspective
and then group up the students
in in small groups and say look at each
of these questions and figure out which
ones you're most interested in trying to
figure out
and pose hypotheses and
figure out what the predictions would be
that follow from those hypotheses and
then we're going to get back together
and you'll make these posters we're
going to put them all around the room
and we're going to go through each group
and talk about
at least one or two of these hypotheses
and the predictions that follow them
from each of the initial observations
and it is so amazingly revealing about
just so many aspects of science you know
how you know
for someone i would often do this either
the afternoon or the same day or the
next day
but for people who had literally never
considered some observation or some
hypothesis before
how fiercely wedded they became to that
thing how just adamant they were that
this has to be the truth
like wow you didn't even think of this
24 hours ago and just recognize how
fiercely wedded you are to this now
okay also take a look at these
predictions that you have from that
follow from
this hypothesis no they don't or they
also would follow from your alternative
hypothesis therefore they're not
predictions of one or the other they're
predictions of both therefore they can't
help you discriminate between the
hypotheses
um how many how many giant questions
that you simply can't answer at that
level scientifically
had to be teased apart into smaller bits
that is not apparent until you've
actually done this exercise so
you know this this was the little bit by
which i
i you know almost every quarter that i
taught was trying to teach people how to
begin
to formulate you know observation
pattern recognition hypothesis
generation
prediction generation yep i definitely
see it as
a hugely valuable exercise the
degree to which um students who don't
grok
what a hypothesis is are always left
groping for how you go about formulating
it now
sometimes they happen onto a method but
it's very often not some method we've
conveyed the point is well think about
it
right what might explain the thing
you're seeing and the answer is
well your brain's a black box and either
it can figure out how to do that trick
or it can't
and if i you know what i did i
showed them i just modeled it right yeah
the point is
i don't know that i ever taught a
student to do it but the point is by
modeling
what you're trying to get to then some
of them find their own method for doing
it but again
it doesn't i mean modeling is a kind of
teaching oh i mean i guess that's
that's the distinction i'm making that
when you say you can't teach this i
think
boy education looks a lot of ways that i
wouldn't have thought it did 20 years
ago
this is exactly the point i'm making i'm
not saying you can't mentor it
right but you can't teach it right
there's not an exercise
by the distinction well all right i mean
i'm i'm
quite convinced of it based on my
interactions
with my mentors who i think did it very
differently
than i do and um the best mentors knew
it
and so the point was they cultivated
they were good
sounding boards but they didn't you know
they never set about trying to
you know give me a method or show me how
to how to accomplish that thing but
anyway
let's let's table that for the moment
and uh
move on all right so um
if if good education but not great
education does successfully engage
in third-person epistemics in which it
tries to provide
a way through philosophy of science and
logic and analysis
um to understand the world and engage in
sense making of the world if not of
yourself or of the other people in
um in it um compare that
that good education to um
this which our producer and
sixteen-year-old son
zachary um pointed
me to yesterday in the new york times
op-ed pages so
my screen is not why is it so slow
um yeah i don't know what's going on
there
hopefully it comes up because i can't
read it otherwise um
oh here we go okay so the opinion from
february 18th op-ed page um
don't go down the rabbit hole critical
thinking as we're taught to do it isn't
helping in the fight against
misinformation
oh boy so as it turns out you know this
starts as this kind of
banal not surprising um
not it shouldn't be controversial
suggestion that actually every time you
run into something on
on the internet um that you think might
not be true you don't actually need to
spend 15 minutes chasing it down like
you you are not obliged to spend 15
minutes chasing down every single thing
that you run into in the internet
boy if you needed to hear that advice
from the new york times you've probably
got a deeper problem
but it gets
this op-ed gets crazy here
first we have four simple principles
which you know at
first glance they seem reasonable when
applied appropriately
um refining the practice and this is um
he says we
suggested modeling the process after the
way professional fact checkers assess
information uh
we've refined the practice into four
simple principles stop
investigate the source find better
coverage
trace claims quotes and media to the
original context
otherwise known as sift for the initial
letters of the four points
stop investigate find and trace mr
caulfield so now i'm gonna just read a
couple of paragraphs here from
um from three paragraphs from this op-ed
mr caulfield walked me through the
process using an instagram post from
robert f kennedy jr
a prominent anti-vaccine activist
falsely alleging a link between the
human papillomavirus vaccine and cancer
quote if this is not a claim or i have a
depth of understanding that i want to
stop for a second and before going
further just investigate the source mr
caulfield said
he copied mr kennedy's name in the
instagram post and popped it into google
look how fast this is he told me as he
counted the seconds out loud
in 15 seconds he navigated to wikipedia
and scrolled through the introductory
section of the page highlighting with
his curse at the last sentence
which reads that mr kennedy is an
anti-vaccine activist and a conspiracy
theorist
is robert f kennedy jr the best on
biased source and information about a
vaccine i'd argue no and that's good
enough to know we should probably just
move on he said
he probed deeper into the method to find
better coverage by copying the main
claim in mr kennedy's post and pasting
that into google search
the first two results came from ajahn's
franz press's fact check website
and the national institutes of health
his quick searches showed a pattern and
here it is
quote mr kennedy's claims were outside
the consensus
a sign they were motivated by something
other than science
i'm just going to read that again just
you know mr kennedy's claims were
outside the consensus
a sign they were motivated by something
other than science
i think someone doesn't know what
science is yes you should say i
rest my case at the point someone has
said something like that
out loud you know just how far they are
from an understanding of how science
works
what scopes might be don't dig deep
people ever
just trust the authorities and whenever
anything doesn't match the consensus
you know that they're not using science
well i would even point out there's
something even weirder in this which is
that the fact that they check
is not the question about hpv the fact
they check is whether or not
uh it's a rotational smear is
a reliable source as if that's a factual
assessment right and you know and
the very article introduces him by
calling him
you know a conspiracy theorist and
anti-vaccine guy right and
yeah like it's a totally separate
question as to what his positions
actually are in vaccines and how nuanced
they
they are or are not the fact
that we are being in form of the
conclusion
as we are then ex we are told how to
come to that conclusion and the way that
we are told to come to that
conclusion is deeply deeply flawed and
suggests a misunderstanding
of how it is that our understanding of
reality advances
you know if you're outside of the
consensus you must not be understanding
or dealing with science
no actually it's the opposite
yes um in fact what you are really being
told
is that we will do the job of deciding
what is true and we will deliver it to
you in a packaged form
and you just simply have to check
whether it's on the science approved
list
or not when i mean this is wrong in so
many different ways
first of all you'll get this kind of
claim from people who in theory have
gone through
graduate school and gotten an advanced
degree in science
right those people should know better
right they've seen the politics on the
inside they understand
not only that wrong ideas can get
a foothold they understand that things
like the replication crisis
emerge and that those results that were
unreplicable
were wrong to begin with right for all
of the years that people claimed
that they were based on reliable science
there was a hidden flaw that had to do
with the way the statistics were
deployed that told us what was right and
what was wrong
and as daniel says repeatedly in your
conversation with him as we have said
before as well
even if the methods were right when
those methods are applied to the wrong
question
you won't get the right answers the
methods have to be
right they have to be applied carefully
the people who apply them have to be
um willing to sacrifice their own career
well-being
in the interest of finding the truth
which is not a common characteristic for
people
and it's not a characteristic that
science
programs now select for they select for
people who are ruthlessly interested
in advancing their own careers which is
antithetical to the
um the instinct that that is necessary
so the number of ways that the
established consensus conclusion can be
wrong
is indefinitely large and we are living
in an era where those conclusions are
increasingly rotten
and to to at this same moment be dealing
with a question of whether or not there
is a
responsible way to check whether
something is true it involves
seeing whether the person who said it is
in some way defective and at the point
you discover they're defective they're
obviously wrong right that's not a
method i recognize
that's um yeah that's a uh that's a mind
virus right there
yep all right so um
this leads us to many other places are
are we where you wanted to go
with that lead away okay so i want to
um point us to what i think
in the last week or so has been has
become clear
as uh the next attack vector against
reason against enlightenment values
against liberalism against all sorts of
things that
longtime listeners to this podcast
will be well familiar with and it's hard
to know where to start with this but i
want to point out something
about the very special nature of zero
now zero is a special number it has
always been a special number it has
unique properties mathematically
speaking
it is strange enough that although it's
hard for us moderns to grok what this
means and i still don't know that i do
grok what this means
the greeks didn't even have the concept
of zera zero
the maya did right it's one of the ways
in which they actually out did the
greeks they are in many ways
parallel to the greeks for the new world
much less known to us because
almost none of what they accomplished
survived in textual form but nonetheless
having a concept of zero gives a
civilization a huge edge
zero is mathematically special but it is
also special
with respect to the battle to control
narratives for political purposes
and i'm going to claim actually
borrowing somewhat from
arnold kluge's file cabinet which sat at
the entrance to his office and had a
note on it
that said it's about power and limited
resources stupid
and this never needed any explanation
because
those who stopped to notice it all
understood what he was getting at which
was that this is
the the reason that humans get involved
in conflict and i'm going to claim that
this is true
with respect to the conflict over not
only what the correct narrative
is but what the allowable tools
are for it to progress right we are
being sold an
absolutely authoritarian version
in which the only kind of truth is the
aristotelian
or the personal right the middle layer
is not allowed to even exist
and so my point about zero is this
in a world in which the scientific
consensus is going to be synchronized to
something wrong
right it is necessary that there be no
universities
in which another perspective can survive
right the difference between a universe
in which one
university is able to do something else
and a university in which
no universities are able to do something
else is all the difference in the world
because
if you pick a university at random and
you free it from the forces that
that dictate what the consensus is and
what is allowed to be considered
then that university will win because
what the other universities have done
is they have signed up for basically
methanol right they've signed up for a
brain killer
something that will not allow them to
think clearly and if everybody's on
board with that
then that could in theory be stable now
of course if all american universities
sign up for brain poison
then of course that will put the
universities of countries that don't
subscribe to these same beliefs ahead
so we are in fact opening the door to
for example
um china taking over the special
position that the west has
held by virtue of the west
self-sabotaging
but okay so you've got this question of
zero if one university
opts out and somehow figures out how to
stay alive
then that will be the place that people
send their kids if they want their kids
actually to learn how to think
that place will therefore produce
graduates that are higher quality
the products that they produce will be
more innovative more robust
everything will provide advantage to the
products of
the products and i mean the people that
come from that university so it has to
be zero
in order to win the battle it has to be
zero now
what i want to connect this to is that
the same principle applies
to social media right if they're going
to control
the narrative on social media by
dictating what is misinformation and
what is factual and then having people
thrown off for spreading what they call
misinformation
then it has to be all of the social
media platforms because if it wasn't we
would all
end up finding the one platform in which
this wasn't happening
right now if it is happening everywhere
what will happen is somebody will say
hey i'll start the platform where you
can say anything you want
okay now you've just invented parlor and
the attack vector is clear
the attack vector is okay parlor is
where the bad people are
and so we at amazon and apple and
google are uh positioned to shut down
the network of bad people you know um
so the um the concern
is that clubhouse is different
right because clubhouse actually
invented a new way instead of
duplicating twitter
what clubhouse did was it invented a new
way of interacting now there's nothing
truly new about it it's just people
talking to each other
but the point is because it was novel
and useful and different
all sorts of people ended up there you
can't very well accuse it of being the
place where the bad people gather
because the bad people may be there but
they're there with all sorts of people
who
uh you know are well within twitter's
good graces
so the point is this now has to be
attacked one way or the other right
somehow the place where conversations
are taking place that can't go on on
twitter
because um twitter has been effective at
shaping the narrative and is
increasingly
aggressive and so of course the new york
times uh
you know said out loud this last week
exactly the thing that is supposed to be
said only quietly within
within certain rooms and they suggested
that clubhouse was a place where
unfettered conversations were taking
place
now that is an amazing an amazing
misstep on their part acknowledging that
at some level
there's something troubling about people
freely exchanging ideas
well so i mean i pulled up their tweet
oh wait
um so this is this is
their tweet about it unfettered
conversations are taking place on
clubhouse
an invitation only app that lets people
gather in audio chat rooms the platform
is exploded in popularity despite
grappling with concerns over harassment
misinformation and privacy um and you
know you can they got
they got seriously ratioed here and they
got five times as many
comments as they do likes on this thing
although a lot of retweets as well i
don't know how many quote tweets
but i just i just searched when i was
looking for their article i searched on
the new york times page
for the word unfettered and one of the
things i found
was uh december 23rd 2011 unfettered was
the word of the day
at the new york times and their
definition is simply not
bound by shackles and chains so i
this that strikes me as um
as free of connotation actually and if
anything
has a positive connotation so i don't
think i don't think a focus on this word
i mean
and it's possible they have edited the
the article originally like i don't know
what all has gone behind the scenes the
new york times
um but i'm not sure what the hubbub is
about this word oh the hubbub is
very well deserved for one thing um the
report
came from somebody who's been traveling
on clubhouse and has been
uh you know a tattletail
nanny hall monitor type so um the point
is in this context yes maybe in 2011
unfettered was a word without such
connotations but at the moment
this has everything to do with an
intense fervor for regulating speech and
my point would be free speech
is effectively a synonym for unfettered
conversation
they are supposed to mean the identical
thing
and uh zach could you bring up the um
the governmental news release that i
sent you
so i unfortunately can you make it
bigger
okay so this is the house committee on
energy and commerce which has
once again summoned the ceos
of tech platforms to answer
for what it calls um the misinformation
and disinformation plaguing
online platforms right so this has a
very definite valence to it and i
i want to put this in a new context
here we have the government
castigating and interrogating ceos of
platforms
that do have the ability to censor
because they are not covered by the
first amendment because they are private
whether that should be or shouldn't be
we can discuss and should discuss
but the fact is for the moment they have
the ability to censor
their terms of service are absolutely
opaque unfollowable and therefore you
can be tossed off at
will which has happened to me of course
but
i would argue that this here with um the
house committee
in the hands of the blue team
um uh putting forth this
um this news release
in which it creates the impression that
misinformation and disinformation are
plaguing online platforms now i'm not
saying that there is not a tremendous
amount of misinformation and
disinformation on online platforms as
there is
you know discussed in every restaurant
in you know the world
this information is a part of human
communication but what they are doing
is they are effectively using something
that i will call a five eyes gambit
the five eyes are five nations
that conspired to subvert
constitutional protections the five
nations are the us
canada uk new zealand and australia i
believe
and the idea was in the u.s there are
strict prohibitions
against spying on u.s citizens but those
prohibitions don't apply for example to
the brits they can spy on u.s citizens
so to the extent that these countries
wanted to spy on their own citizens
they could basically unionize spy on
each other's citizens and exchange the
information
voila no more constitutional protections
right
so what's going on here spying circle
jerk
it's a spying circle jerk okay so what's
going on here
the government right and it'd be pretty
hard to deny that the house committee on
energy and commerce is not part of the
government the government is forbidden
to regulate speech so what's it going to
do it is going to threaten
these online platforms and get them to
regulate speech
right is that a violation of the first
amendment
thematically it is very specifically a
violation of the first amendment
is it exempt because of the one-step
removed
nature of it right i think it you know
that's the the argument that's going to
be made but the real point is
the um even the title of the article
that you quoted
simply assumes a fight against
misinformation
right it never stops to engage the
question
of why it is that speech is protected
the way it is in spite of the fact that
there is lots of misinformation
contained
in speech inherently so right why did
the founders
protect abhorrent speech they did so
because the
net value of keeping speech free in
spite of abhorrence speech
is positive remains positive this is
something we all understood until
yesterday to use
douglas murray's formulation and so we
are about to lose this because
everybody does understand that
misinformation spreads online and that
bad things happen as a result of it
right but if that's all you focus on
then you think well great let's just
shut down the misinformation but
what we don't do is ever get to the
question of
what is a fact there are certain facts
you can check
right but the number of things that
would be claimed to be factual that are
not
actually factual the number of places
where something that would have been
claimed to be factual
is forced to be reversed on the basis
that people doggedly point out
the evidence that it was not indeed true
you're going to shut down that mechanism
in other words this is the end of
thought this is the beginning of
here's your predigested narrative now
take it it's certainly the end of public
thought
and it sends um all of the
not quite fitting into established
ideological framework thought
underground into private and that means
they're
at the moment with coveted lockdowns
there's gonna be a lot less of it
um but that will drive underground both
the necessary
important actually discovering of
reality that will help us
survive into you know the next century
thought um from happening
and it will also drive the actual
hateful fringe disgusting
thought underground out of you such that
when it explodes onto the scene
later you know everyone's gonna act
surprised like you did this to us
like we what is language
actually if not a place and a way
to explore things that some of which are
true
some of which aren't and many of which
we don't yet know
this this is the point the idea that we
you know it is
just such hubris it is there's such an
arrogance to this perspective
that we already know everything about
what is true
and right and just and you can trust us
to just keep your frail fragile brains
away from all the stuff
that we already know isn't true and is
dangerous like
that is not if any society that did that
went extinct quickly that's what
happened
yep um you you absolutely can't do this
and i i
just you know we could go on literally
we could go on for days coming up with
examples of things that if you allow
the fact checkers to decide what we can
discuss with each other
will be frozen in place and we will
never actually make the jump to what
turns out to be true
in the end and i would point out just
you know an example
kerry mullis the inventor of pcr won a
nobel prize for pcr pcr being
one of the most powerful techniques in
molecular biology right he
had doubts that hiv caused aids
these were not preposterous delusional
doubts now he was wrong i believe
he was factually wrong but the point is
you had a super genius
right somebody who brought a tremendous
amount of value to the world
who could not falsify in his mind
the idea that hiv and aids might be two
distinct phenomena
that co-travel enough that we can fool
ourselves into believing one is causal
of the other
now do you want to do the same thing to
him that they're doing to
to bobby kennedy jr right you know is
carrie mullis
you know a crazed unreliable scientific
source because he holds a belief
that is in fact potentially dangerous
you need to protect yourself from hiv if
you don't want to get aids
and so you know there's no denying that
if this is indeed a wrong hypothesis of
his that it has potential consequences
for human life and limb but the point is
no we have to take
the package that is kerry mullis rather
than say oh you're not entitled to think
because uh you sometimes do it wrong
well guess what we all sometimes do it
wrong notorious hiv aids deny or carry
mullis
right right exactly and then the other
thing
is i'm just stunned by the fact that we
are having this discussion about
stamping out misinformation at the same
time that we are having this
unusual discussion about the lab leak
origin hypothesis for covid19 which is
the rare case where in fact
an idea that many wanted to stamp out
you know a year ago
doesn't die and we are in fact you know
managing to convince people that it is a
viable hypothesis which it clearly is
um so you know again do you want to stop
that conversation because frankly if
you'd stop that conversation we'd all
still believe it was pangolins
and we now know it wasn't pangolins and
you know that's normal hypothesizing
that it was pangolins on the basis of
some evidence
that's a totally normal phenomenon
discovering that that actually doesn't
make sense in light of the fact that for
example
pangolins don't normally get
coronaviruses and the coronavirus
doesn't the coronavirus that we have
covid19
sars kobe 2 doesn't infect them
effectively
right that those things have to update
our model and the point is if you
think that the model is just something
you get in a software update
and it's fully packaged and the facts
are what they are and we can just shut
down
you know all of the messiness that is
outside of the established consensus
well you don't have the first thing you
have the first bit of knowledge about
how we got here the magic of
civilization
involves the messiness that's why the
first amendment looks the way it does
and it's why it has to apply in one way
or another to the tech platforms
absolutely so um i i don't have it to
show but also this week i believe
um the wikipedia entry for the loudly
hypothesis
was actually taken down right it was
fact-checked
out of existence by what turns out to be
a small band of motivated activists
okay so um you you i guess had this
pulled
pulled up uh so this is there was for a
brief time a covet 19 lab leak
hypothesis
notice the phrasing not lab leak theory
lab leak hypothesis page
that very responsibly chronicled the
evidence for the lab leak hypothesis
and it was taken down
as a result of an incessant
and very powerful campaign by a small
number of people
behind the scenes there is some evidence
that that campaign
involved uh what would be called a water
army
a water army being a chinese phenomenon
in which people are hired to make social
media posts
that sway opinion so this is a known
phenomenon
and there is i mean i i assume that
happens all the time i've never heard
the term water army before that i think
it does happen all the time and i think
water army
applies specifically to the chinese
version of it which has been
large scale you know the chinese have
taken a very aggressive
stance with respect to what is tolerated
um on the internet and there is a
battle over uh various platforms in
which chinese
people exchange information under the
radar
but in any case i guess i'm sorry like
one thing that i do not understand about
this conversation
is um it's you know and i think i said
this on
on the last episode you know like it's
easy to to try to smear those of us who
are talking about it as if
it's because we're anti-chinese you know
we're cynophobic and i think
actually if this does turn out to have
been a leak
as a result of gain of function research
um in
at this lab in wuhan that points the
finger
in if you go back just a little bit more
more at american science and scientists
and
the nih and such than it does to china
and
not to say that um you know china
if if this is true would not have been
involved in a cover-up and all of this
but
the idea that this is um that this would
make china look bad
it would look it would make
a lot of virologists look bad and the
whole program of gain of
function research and serial passaging
look bad
and potentially it would
reveal to us the downstream effects of
the moratorium that the obama
administration put in place precisely
because of the risks of this research
and the mistake presumably that it was
for the trump administration to raise
the moratorium like you know it just it
makes a whole lot of people look bad and
i don't feel like china is
really special in that list well it's
becoming special because it
is behaving in an obstructionist fashion
with respect to the investigation of
this i post
but the who i mean the who's giving them
complete cobra right i i agree this does
not start out
in fact i've got i've got a piece of an
interview here to share as you wanted me
to
okay on that topic um well let's uh
let's finish this out though okay
um so we've got
let's let's take your challenge here
and just notice in a world in which we
are going to decide that scientific
consensus
is the arbiter of what is a fact then
let's map
the lab league hypothesis question onto
it and note the very
um dangerous circumstance we find
ourselves in
either sarsko v2 is an escapee
from the lab or it isn't
if it is an escapee from from the lab in
wuhan
then it suggests something about the
danger of
escapes that you can effectively crash
the world economy
and you know kill millions of people
um by accident because you know
maybe you were doing what you thought
was honorable research but that research
you know the cost benefit analysis
wasn't what you thought it was either
that's true
or it did come from nature if it came
from nature
these things can potentially hop out at
any time and
crash the world economy and kill
millions of people etc etc so the point
is
either the implication is either
we shouldn't have been doing this
research because the danger was way too
big or
we should have been doing it sooner and
bigger and more labs and all of that
stuff
so the point is the decision it's not
just a conflict of interest it's like
you know thrive or die it's not just
like just continue to eke out a fragile
existence
or go down screaming it's like you're
going to either become
the most important types of researchers
in the world
or you are going to be recognized as
having done the research that helped
you know spur the world into a global
pandemic and economic collapse
those who created um this research
program and this was an international
effort those who created it
are either the heroes or the villains of
the story yeah right and
the idea that we are now going to fight
that out on the basis of well if it's a
consensus and it's in wikipedia
then it's a fact and everything else
can't be discussed on social media well
what's going on
you know at wikipedia when you look
behind the scenes you have people openly
discussing
the best tactics for sustaining the
attack that is to say
you know berating people to the point
that they ultimately give up is being
discussed as a tactic
in the editing uh part of wikipedia
so the point is this doesn't have
anything to do with facts this has to do
with people who want that that entry
down for their own reasons whatever they
may be
shaping what the world takes to be a
factual reference now the fact is
i use wikipedia all the time it does
there's certain kinds of things that you
can
you know go in there you know if you
want to look up uh
you know the chemical constituents of a
particular
you know molecule is a pretty good
chance you can find it in there and the
chances that that's subject to some sort
of political
wrangling are pretty low right um but
there are other things in which there's
a lot at stake in which you just can't
rely on it as a factual reference and
there's no mechanism hence
we're stuck with what we call
misinformation and
the thing that scares me most of all is
that the ratio
of misinformation to high quality
heterodox information
is probably a thousand to one on a good
day
right the high quality heterodox
information
is buried in a sea of garbage
and if you get people to focus on the
sea of garbage and you say wouldn't you
like to be
free of this thousand pieces
of bad information wouldn't the world be
better off without them well maybe it
would be but you can't get rid of them
without
getting rid of the secret sauce which is
the one in a thousand pieces that you
absolutely
need to chase down and doesn't have the
defense of hey this is a fact and we all
agree on it
right
all right should we i think we're there
uh well we're not there we're going to
talk
you wanted me to share uh this
uh thing from science from
february 14th politics was always in the
room
who mission chief reflects on china trip
seeking cobia 19's origin so this is an
interview
by by science one of the two most
important scientific journals in the
world
with uh the mission leader peter ben and
barack who we haven't heard as much from
because peter dashik was sort of the
i don't know self-appointed otherly
appointed spokesperson mostly
but let us just
go to a few of these questions here we
go
question at friday's press conference in
geneva ted rose seemed to contradict you
by saying that with respect to the
origins of sars cov2
quote all hypotheses around the table
was it a mistake to call the
lab origin hypothesis extremely unlikely
embark answers
no we first developed a pathway of all
the possible ways the virus could be
introduced into the human population in
late 2019
a lab accident is one hypothesis another
is the direct introduction from an
animal host and others are different
versions of intermediary hosts
for each hypothesis we tried to put
facts on the table look at what we had
in terms of arguments and then make an
assessment of each
it was already a big step to have
chinese colleagues assess and evaluate
such a hypothesis based on what we had
on the table which was not much
yes lab accidents do happen around the
world they have happened in the past
the fact that several laboratories of
relevance are in and around wuhan and
are working with coronavirus is another
fact
beyond that we didn't have much in terms
of looking at that hypothesis as a
likely option
so like asterisk yes you did but okay
let's go back into the interview for a
moment
question and but what led you to use the
extremely unlikely label did you learn
anything that made it less likely
answer again in barack speaking we
should not put too much focus on the
wording
we were looking at different options at
some point we were thinking should we
use a ranking with one being the most
unlikely five the most likely or should
we use colors
or should we find another scale we ended
up with a five phrase scale
extremely unlikely unlikely possible
likely and very likely
it's more an illustration of where these
hypotheses are to help us organize our
planning of future studies
question but my question is whether you
learned anything new in china
now that you've been there do you have
more reason to say it's extremely
unlikely than before
translation answer my damn question dude
answer
again embark yes we had long meetings
with the staff of the wuhan institute of
virology in three other laboratories and
we
can't even do this with a straight face
um they talked about these claims openly
we discussed what did you do over the
past year to dismiss this claim
what did you yourself develop in terms
of argumentations did you do audits
yourself
did you look at your records did you
test your staff and they explained how
they worked and what kind of audit
system they had
they had retrospectively tested serum
from their staff they tested samples
from early 2019 from 2020.
there were a lot of discussions that we
could not have had if we had not
traveled to wuhan
we also did not have evidence provided
by outsiders to support any of the
claims out there
that could potentially have tipped the
balance what we saw and discussed gave
us much more confidence in our
assessment
the consensus was that this is an
unlikely scenario
we also had difficulties designing
future studies to look into the
laboratory claims within our joint group
because if you want to explore such a
hypothesis further
you need a different mechanism you need
to do a formal audit
and that's far beyond what our team is
mandated to do or has the tools and
capabilities to do
so that was also a reason why we could
not start moving forward in our next
series of studies into that direction
but the fact that the hypothesis is
listed or assessed as extremely unlikely
is not the same as if it had been listed
to recess as impossible
we're not closing the door
we're not closing the door because it's
swollen and we can't get it to close
um oh my god yeah i mean it's it's
really it's like
and you're like sorry but like well we
looked at a number of different schemes
you know
probably you wouldn't be upset with us
if we just said it was purple instead of
a highly unlikely like you know we
we thought about using language and we
thought about using colors and we
thought about using like
just because we landed on this scheme
doesn't really mean anything but it does
what are you talking about i thought
about having a guy with a uniform stand
there and say nothing to see here folks
go on home
yeah don't look be i look don't look at
the man behind the curtain don't look at
him
there's infinite numbers of versions of
like what are you doing you're not
compelling
this is not a compelling interview now
interestingly
um let us compare this hey zach you want
to put up the uh
i sent you a paper this is not a
peer-reviewed paper but it takes the
form
of a manuscript and it is by um
authors who actually have advanced a uh
so this is latham and wilson wilson
uh and this paper is basically an
analysis of how likely it is
that china that there is a natural
origin intermediate to be found
which was a large part of the discussion
that we did last week
and they'd attempt to quantify the
chances and
actually this analysis although i'm
going to argue that it is
flawed i think it is flawed in a way
that the natural scientific process
would cause their estimate to be refined
but the analysis centers on some very
interesting and
important pieces of evidence one of them
being
phylogenetic and the other geographic
okay right
and the point is the point of the
analysis is
that if you um look at the chances
of patient zero showing up in wuhan
and the chances that the coronavirus
that
becomes a pandemic is
a beta corona virus
from this particular group that is to
say from the same group
as generated sars cove one
the initial sars that the chances they
calculate the chance if you scroll down
here zach scroll down to
near the end of the article keep going
uh slow down
uh two two two scroll back up a little
bit
well i can't quite find it but they
calculate the um
they calculate the number if you combine
the like oh there it is um
one in 630 that it will be
in wuhan and one in 28 that it will be
a close relative of the original sars
and they calculate the combined number
at one in 17 640.
now i think their number is probably off
by an order of magnitude
but you know it is nonetheless
an impressive degree and you know at
some point i wouldn't mind talking with
the authors of this about how i would
alter
their methodology to make it more robust
but the point is the
the likelihood calculation is so far
away that they actually conclude if you
can go back to it
in the next paragraph
okay scroll down just a little bit
okay here uh there the last sentence of
the next paragraph says a lab escape
should at this point
be the default hypothesis was which
people who listened last week will
remember
was one of the arguments that we made
that which is that effectively
because there is substantial evidence
for a laboratory leak and because
there is not evidence of a natural
intermediate
that in fact lab leak has the
status of the null hypothesis at this
point in other words it is possible it
came from nature but that puts the
burden
on those who would argue that to find
the intermediate and absent that
intermediate the one plausible
intermediate that we have
is the laboratory yeah i'm actually so i
don't i'm not familiar with this paper
this is the first time i've seen it but
i'm liking
what i see here actually the first part
of that paragraph you just read the last
sentence from
the criticism will doubtless be made
that the geographic and the phylogenetic
evidence described here are
circumstantial
mere coincidences but critiquing
evidence is circumstantial is based on a
common logical misconception
that circumstantial evidence represents
a special category of evidence
as the philosopher david hume first
argued all evidence of causation is
composed of coincidences
all an observer can do is to add up the
coincidences until they surmise at the
threshold of reasonable doubt has been
surpassed
conclusions are always provisional but
in the absence of evidence of the
contrary
anyone open to persuasion on at this
point to conclude the probability of
seventeen thousand six hundred forty to
one far exceeds that threshold
a lab escape should this point be the
default hypothesis now i see there that
they've alighted a key
part of the scientific process in their
description there right like that
um if you have the hypothesis before you
find
the um the you know we have talked about
this with regard to correlation and
causation right like
um correlation does not imply causation
unless you predicted it in advance
right and so their their sort of
approach from from
hume centric as opposed to more like
bacon francis bacon-centric which is you
know our
sort of original um approach um
converge i think right and so they land
as well
on this conclusion this is what the
default should be and default hypothesis
the uh so
this makes so many of the right points
because for one thing
uh people who've been with these live
streams since the beginning will
remember
the very early period as we were trying
to sort out what we were
learning about coronavirus and the field
all of the fields involved in this
discussion had moved into a mode
where because there wasn't time for
normal peer review you couldn't wait a
year for your paper to go through
that process we were just working from
the stuff on the archives right
now the stuff on the archives is the
pre-print servers so archive was
the name of one of the pre-print servers
the pre-print servers which are not yet
peer-reviewed
basically it's a place to lodge papers
that take the right form but haven't
been through that process
but it made for a a very
vibrant discussion in which many more
people had
access to the tools it was messy there
was lots of wrong stuff
there right so it didn't have the kind
of quality control
that comes from peer review but the
quality control that comes from peer
review is
anything but a hedge against bad
information making into the literature
there's tons of bad information
and increasingly as we've talked about
before here peer review acts as these
latter day fact checkers where they're
motivated to um you know to a particular
kind of research
type of conclusion people in particular
that they want to have published et
cetera
right now what i would point out is that
this paper which as far as i know
is not peer-reviewed it takes the form
of a peer-reviewed paper but it's
published in a source that doesn't peer
review i think
it is logically evaluatable
i have concerns about the way it was
done and one of the conclusions is
interesting so these people advanced
a hypothesis earlier that the
intermediate was the
one of the minors in the uh the yunnan
mine from which samples were taken and
they have a a model in which the lungs
of that minor basically served as a
serial passage experiment
now i don't think this can be the case
but it is a viable hybrid one of the
miners who died
or what i actually don't think it
matters
i don't think we know what we don't have
is any evidence that those miners
transmitted the virus to anybody
um so if it you know if it is a lab
so their their idea is it's a lab leak
and that the sample was transmitted to
the lab from which it leaked but the
sample
was enhanced in the lungs of these
miners through a natural evolutionary
process
i don't believe that this can be the
case why uh
well for a number of reasons one
i believe that the selection a i don't
believe that there's enough room for
that selection to have taken place
um in a single individual but there are
well and this is part of why i asked you
one of the ones who i
as i understood it i thought that there
were only you know a handful of people
who got it and they all died
six three done okay so you know this
wouldn't this
seems more plausible to me if it's the
la
from the lungs of one of the miners who
survived and therefore it may have had
more
um basically more generations in which
to
in which to evolve within the lungs of
that minor yeah i agree
although if we're talking about sars
kovi ii
um you know then we're talking about
something that the immune system does
get wise to
and you know ultimately wins that battle
so anyway we can talk about i agree that
if you lived there was a longer period
of time potentially
for that evolution to take place but i
don't believe a single miner's lungs
are going to be enough i remain to be
convinced of whether that's true but
here's the other problem is that there
are two factors
in the um
the amazing capacity of sarsko v2 at the
point it shows up and hits the ground
running in wuhan
right it's very good at invading tissues
and it's very good at getting between
individuals
and all of the selection in the miner's
lungs
would have been in favor of invading
tissues it would not be super well
adapted
and as far as we know didn't go between
tissues either
it didn't go between individuals didn't
go between tissues well that would
certainly be an interesting question i
don't think we know that that's true
because they died of what was called uh
i don't think it was even called
viral pneumonia was understood to be an
ammonia we now know it was a viral
pneumonia
um but uh it would be very interesting
to know
you know what a full uh necropsy would
would have revealed about
um what other tissues were affected yeah
there's a lot that could be
settled if we had those samples which i
believe we just simply don't and they
might actually exist in somebody's
freezer somewhere which is another
reason that we need to
answer this this question right but
nonetheless
these authors say
they do exactly the right thing they lay
out all of their work
right that work can be evaluated i
believe that they're off
by something like a factor of 10 which
still leaves a
very impressive you know 1760 to 1
uh burden which is way um
or um indication of direction
which is you know i've only gone i've
said i think it's 90
or above that's well above that um but
in any case the natural process can now
unfold here
outside of those who would fetter the
conversation right
we can yeah darn those federers
i always liked how he played well i mean
he's gifted but
but nonetheless he's not a uh he's not a
hero of free speech
he might be i don't know sorry roger
that that was uncalled for on my part as
far as i know
you might be a hero free spiritual i'm
just not not aware of it but
in any case we can now have the
discussion and say look here's how i
would modify your method so that your
approximation of the chances of this
having happened uh by random would be
uh more accurate might be i'm wrong
we'll find out
you know it might be there wrong they
adjust their number we could get a
better number but the point is it's
still a pretty impressive
the analysis itself you know how you uh
numeritize it is that a word no no
okay i propose numeritize becomes a word
but uh
but okay how do you modify it how do you
quantify it
it's an open question but the analysis
itself uh
is i believe logically robust and very
persuasive
and i suggest the burden of proof
therefore you know we are both you don't
see any sign errors you think the
the the size of the of
the estimate is off i think the size of
the estimate is off but the point is
it's uh
the estimate is so profound that even at
a tenth their strength it's still
uh overwhelming remarkable um and then i
think the question about you know they
say there are four
lab league hypotheses it is very likely
that their their estimate on
um the strength of that likelihood is
that it is one of these
and their point is we have advanced one
it could be any of the four or another
but um it's likely to be in that
quadrant and not a natural origin
and that is certainly an excellent place
to have a high quality scientific
discussion
all right well um given that it's two
o'clock here already now we still need
to talk about dung beetles maybe we
should move on
yep okay um zachary
while you're showing a video we can talk
over it right because there's no sound
really in the video
uh or you can mute it i mean there's
sound of rustling
that could be interesting jungle noises
yeah i think there's not
yeah so this video um
is one i just took with my iphone um at
tipputini
in the far um in the far western amazon
in ecuador
uh like i said 13 months ago when you
and i were there
for two and a half weeks working on our
book and exploring
and just generally being being tropical
biologists
and you know you see this thing um that
is familiar to people who
know nature documentaries of this beetle
who has
rolled up a nice perfectly spherical
ball of poop
and uh is backing it up and i think
that's and that's it i had a number of
these but i just sent
zach a 30 second
um video so dung beetles are almost
worldwide
interestingly um they you know the
scarabs uh like that one
that are often really brilliantly
colored or um i don't know if they're
pan tropical but they're certainly
neotropical they don't i don't think the
really brightly colored dung beetles
tend to get into the temperate zone so
much
like mangroves and sidewinders which we
discussed in episode 66
they are um not just widespread but
convergent
so um this this habit of finding poop
and rolling it into balls and
and rolling it or funneling it or
tunneling it or whatever um
for personal use did not evolve just
once and adaptively radiate out into
into the world um but this was
convergently arrived upon solution to
the problem of
how to get resources and also what are
we going to do with all this poop that
we found
by a number of different lineages of
beetles so that that alone is sort of
interesting right like i didn't
i hadn't thought too much about dung
beetles although every time i did a
study abroad
program there were a few students who
wanted to do one of their one day
one or two day field exercises on the
ecology of dung beetles which would
allow them of course to
drop trousers and poop in the rainforest
and wait for the dung beetles to arrive
that's the easy way that's that's that's
the easy way um
and uh and you know they really are
ubiquitous enough
and driven enough by the smell of fresh
excrement that
you can reliably get dung beetles to
come to fresh poop
in at least in the neotropics and in
fact i should just point out there's an
excellent book called tropical nature
it's right there
in which uh oh yeah
um tropical nature here um
which uh has
the proposal in it for this uh
experiment in other words it proposes
that if you're going to work
um in the tropics that you uh you do
take a poop in the woods and then uh
step back and watch what happens because
um
things happen fast in tropical forests
yeah right well so this book
which is the subtitle of which is life
and death in the rainforest of central
and south america
was always something i assigned before
we went on study abroad
and so you know they um i think i think
you would come upon this if you were
trying to figure out
uh what you might do for a day or two
long project in the rainforest and
you've come to recognize that actually
monkeys are a problem because they move
around all the time and you have to put
them to sleep and then get up before
they get up if you want any chance of
finding them the next day for instance
whereas if all you have to do
is uh is poop and wait it's
rather an easier project um and um
but but you know this book is is
extraordinary
um but science this week um
the reason that i wanted to say anything
about dung beetles right now
is not because uh i was thinking about
them otherwise but science this week
has this article um it's not it's not a
research article it's a news article
um titled humble dung beetles maybe
ideal dna detectors for animal surveys
and so i'm not i'm not going to read
anything from it that's that's that's
really all
um all right there and the idea is um
that a lot of what some types of
biologists are
doing sort of you know as especially
conservation biologists
um is trying to establish who
who's where like what species are in a
particular area by doing these surveys
and there's a lot of you know you can do
audio surveys and you listen and you can
you know
most most you know you can do um you
know transects and you know
you could do camera traps and you know
lay cameras in fact at tippatini
um diego moscara who had been the um
the director at tippatini and is now i
think the director of research
um had one of the most extensive camera
trap studies i've ever
i've ever seen and maybe has been done
to date in in a tropical
field situation and he caught you know
there's like five species of cats
and oh boy what is it 10 or 10 or 12
species of monkeys and he wasn't mostly
seeing the monkeys because these were
down low but
you know and just incredible number of
you know
charismatic megafauna that otherwise
weren't being seen that he was finding
with these
with these game cameras camera traps
but really rare stuff is really hard to
find
and we would like to know what what's
out there
and one way to do it is being proposed
is well
these these dung beetles um often
are specifically collecting mammalian
dung
and the dna of the mammals who [ __ ] out
that
dung remains viable as fragments of you
know identifiable fragments of dna from
that species for apparently 48 hours
after the dung beetle takes it in and so
you have to sacrifice the beetle
to get the dna um but it is being
proposed and has just begun to be
um so they're not talking about using
the dung balls themselves
to get the dna no they're talking about
using the stomach contents of the
beetles now why
why not use the dung balls themselves
yeah i don't know
and it's not even explored here yeah uh
probably because they're gonna use light
traps to get the beetles
and they're not gonna be able to finding
the beetles is not gonna be all that
easy either it's gonna be very
labor intensive but putting up a uv
light will
uh well no actually the so you just
landed on it um
basically just as i said what i landed
on it
um just as you know our students and my
students um
who were interested in looking at dung
beetle ecology in part because you can
get them to come to you
yeah um they're not gonna use light
drops they're gonna you know they're
gonna
[ __ ] in the woods really they're gonna
file that in their grant well
um you know it's been it's at least um
implied
in this little science news article
interesting yeah oh
okay well that that's that's fascinating
so no doubt so
you know finding dung beetles with balls
is
with dung balls is you know somewhat
easy to do
in in at least in your tropical forest
and i've seen them in madagascar too but
you know
i've never spent really any time in the
other
tropical forests of the world um but you
can reliably
every single time attract dung beetles
with fresh poop
yeah you just can't yep no that's true
they'll find you um
they're not using light drive okay well
i would advise they use live traps or at
least say that that's we're gonna that
they're gonna do in their grant
application
but um the but i mean i think in part
the whole like the whole reason that
this is
useful is oh my god any day we want we
can go and get dung beetles
and um and you know light traps you kill
a lot of other insects you attract a lot
of stuff you don't want you know it's
like
and you you don't i don't even know to
what degree dung beetles particularly
come to light traps
uh i'm trying to remember i've certainly
been around enough light traps i believe
they
they are actually relatively frequent
but i've seen scarabs but i haven't seen
i don't i don't know that i've seen dung
beetles scarabs of course some
giant category well anyway
uh don't know to draw the circle a
little closer here though
kerry mullis invents pcr no doubt the
technique that they will use to amplify
the little pieces of dna
from the dung beetles um and so anyway
that technique is now
everywhere including uh covet tests
indeed
indeed um all right
i think we've reached the end uh we have
begun
to show the picture that we'll use on
the thumbnail at the end but maybe we
showed it early on
yeah i think it's gonna end up being uh
one of those uh
ice pictures or yeah or drunk without
power drunk without power yeah could be
that one yeah
um all right so we're gonna take uh for
those of you watching a 15-minute break
and come back with a live q a
ask your questions in super chat now or
in the next hour and we'll get to as
many of them as we can
um for those of you listening we will be
back at the same time next
week and hopefully so we did not we
weren't able to put out
um the conversation that you had with
someone who showed me nameless until it
comes out
this last week because of our power
outage but hopefully um you've now got
two
banked yeah um so two conversations
coming at least one of those is going to
come out hopefully between now and next
saturday
um please consider joining us at my
patreon for dark horse membership
right now is the question asking period
is open
and not tomorrow but next sunday we'll
have the two hour private q a
um one little blip of last month's
private q a
is of uh is brett talking about his
first hatched
child the crocodile which i think i say
on air i wouldn't do this to you if it
was going out to youtube and then
um i said yeah right on youtube so yeah
why not um you
join brett on his patreon for
conversations every month we've got
merchandise available at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org and we should
have some new stuff up soon hopefully
email our moderator darkhorse.miter
gmail.com with logistical questions
and boy there's probably other stuff but
i think i'm out
yep um that's uh that's it we will uh
i guess have the winner of the clubhouse
invite um by the top of the next hour um
uh dr rollergator will be doing the
choosing and uh you can tell him whether
you want your
name announced as the winner or kept
secret
all right uh thanks everyone we'll see
you in 15 minutes
get outside